supposed to reduce your power bill one
homeowner who turned to solar energy
says that's not what's happened until
the 8 news now investigators stepped in
vanessa murphy brings us the story of a
solar panel fail which ended up with a
fix
i trust both the installer and the
designer eve kaganovic says when she
invested in solar energy for her las
vegas valley home she expected the
panels to soak up the desert sun and for
her power bill to drop i believe in
solar but i'm
trusting to a fault that's not what
happened it seems obvious since the
solar panels were installed these trees
have been here for 30 years
in the shade no source
of sunlight during
the fall and winter months
in order to produce any energy for me
and therefore i'm
incurring all of the costs of the power
bill about half of the year when the
solar panels are getting sunshine her
power bill is about 13
when they're not the bill is more than
200
that's along with our monthly payment
for the solar panels at more than 250
dollars from a 25-year loan to pay the
solar panels off an investment of more
than 70 thousand dollars kaganovic says
legacy designed the plan titan installed
it and she asked them both to move the
panels into a better spot on her roof
she says the companies blamed each other
and refused to move the panels so she
reached out to the eight news now
investigators i just want them relocated
after we sent emails and made phone
calls to both companies beginning with a
struggle to even reach a human on the
phone legacy pointed to titan and
replied in part we no longer have a
business relationship with the company
titan replied in part the company was
under the impression the issue was
resolved by legacy and a spokeswoman
said still though titan would relocate
the panels they are going to move the
solar panels tomorrow morning thank you
of course
the next morning i can't express how
happy i am
a crew showed up i feel like i've been
fighting for over a year
and trying to get somewhere and
i
can't believe
in just a week or two what you guys have
been able to do so thank you thank you
so much channel 8. now those panels are
in the sunshine where they should have
been from the start
reporting in the northwest valley
vanessa murphy 8 news now